su médico puede recomendarle una
reparación artroscópica del manguito
rotador si el manguito rotador está
dañado el manguito rotador está formado
por cuatro músculos y tendones que
sujetan la cabeza del hueso superior del
brazo el húmero firmemente dentro de la
articulación del hombro
y los músculos del manguito rotador
tiran de las bandas de tejido resistente
inelástico llamados tendones a fin de
levantar y girar el brazo mientras se
mantiene estable la articulación del
hombro un desgarro del manguito rotador
hace que el movimiento del brazo sea
doloroso y limitado o imposible
dependiendo de la gravedad del desgarro
en las lesiones más graves el tendón se
desgarra de su lugar fijo en la cabeza
del húmero puesto que el suministro de
sangre para los tendones es deficiente
un tendón del manguito rotador no será
capaz de curarse a sí mismo después de
un desgarro completo y usted necesitará
cirugía su manguito rotador puede estar
lesionado debido a caer levantar
hablar
o hacer movimientos repetitivos del
brazo por encima de la cabeza tales como
lanzamientos natación y pintura además
el uso y desgaste normal que acompaña al
envejecimiento puede debilitar y romper
los tendones
y su cirujano comenzará por hacer dos
cortes pequeños en su piel para tener
acceso al interior del hombro luego su
cirujano insertará una artroscopia este
dispositivo contiene una linterna y una
cámara e instrumentos quirúrgicos
diminutos el artroscopio proyectará
imágenes a través de la pantalla de tv
para guiar el trabajo de su cirujano su
cirujano realizará unos pequeños cortes
adicionales utilizando pequeñas
herramientas para examinar la
articulación de su hombro en busca de
tejido enfermo y reparar el tendón
desgarrado luego su cirujano hará un par
de orificios en su hueso
en donde se colocarán unos implantes
llamados suturas de anclaje el cirujano
hará suturas a través de los anclajes
y los unirá al tendón reparado para
volver a conectar el tendón al hueso los
anclajes y las suturas se absorberán
gradualmente en los tejidos de
cicatrización
al finalizar el procedimiento su
cirujano sacará los instrumentos
artroscópico y cerrará sus incisiones
con puntos después del procedimiento el
hombro será colocado en un cabestrillo
para que tenga apoyo y protección usted
pasará algunas horas en la sala de
recuperación y lo más probable es que se
vaya a casa el mismo día